un dimanche matin de janvier la place de
la constitution paraît bien tranquille
mais mexico s'anime à grande vitesse
[Musique]
un québécois se trouve sur place par
affaire depuis 2002 je venais tout les
assauts fin 2013
ça n'est devenu une habitude face à la
pénurie de la main-d'oeuvre
le maraîcher guy pouliot tu as pris les
grands moyens il est l'un des rares
producteurs agricoles canadien a
sélectionné lui même ses employés sans
intermédiaire ni agence ce sont les
mexicains qui ont permis l'expansion de
sa ferme à l'île d'orléans 213 y
travaillent déjà
c'est son poids là on n'est pas non plus
se déplacer en vaut le coup il estime
que la fidélité de sa main d'oeuvre lui
procure une augmentation de productivité
de 10 % ministère du travail du mexique
ces hommes attendent depuis le milieu de
l'année décidé à changer de vie quand on
sait que le salaire minimum au québec et
dix fois celui du mexique
quatre ont des enfants les prennent la
peine de s'expatrier en catégorie tour
il ya une motivation
le choix des candidats a été réalisée
par le gouvernement mexicain
mais la sélection finale revient à guy
pouliot
les travailleurs mexicains au canada ont
une scolarité de base et doivent être
âgés d'au moins 21 ans et provenir
obligatoirement deux régions rurales les
candidats donc cinq minutes pour
convaincre les hommes sont pas
tranquilles sont vaillants et
responsables prêts à travailler 60
heures semaine et même plus c'est les
fraises sont prêtes accueilli ces mots
qu'ils ne jouent leur avenir en quelque
sorte car au canada la moitié des
travailleurs mexicains qui réussissent à
être embauchés sont toujours à l'emploi
d'une ferme
après dix ans
à la ferme pilote un travailleur
mexicain garnier entre 12 et 22 mille
dollars selon la durée de son séjour
total patronyme en 1974 à la création du
programme d'embauché canada mexique des
travailleurs temporaires
le mexique avait envoyé au canada 203
personnes en 2018 c'était 100 fois plus
nous croyons que la mobilité légal
ordonnée et sécuritaires y ce qui doit
gérer cette complémentarité des marchés
du travail en deux jours 300 candidats
ont eu droit à une entrevue
malheureusement plusieurs seront d'issue
la sécheresse de 2018 entraîné une
diminution de 20% des volumes de ce cui
et les hausses répétées du salaire
minimum depuis 2016 on crée une pression
additionnelle
quand la moitié des dépenses c'est les
salaires ça fait en sorte que cette
année on avait un groupe de 60
sélectionnés ou de 90 ou cinq comme le
passé pour les candidats qui ne seront
pas retenus
il reste la possibilité de viser une
place ailleurs au canada
ici rachel brillant radio canada québec